again I'm gonna approach it by cases
okay and it's not that hard you start to
see the pattern very quickly rather than
develop it by quadrants which you saw
before I'm gonna do the kind of quick
version okay so for instance where x and
y are both positive where XY both
positive I'm going to take the positive
case for both of these right through the
positive x it was positive Y we know
exactly what that looks like that's fine
okay and just rather than going around
in like a clock right I'm just gonna get
straight to the opposite quadrant think
about what's happening over here
and how it's an analog for what's
happening up here X positive negative
negative Y positive they're both
negative so I'll take the negative case
for put which means negative x negative
Y which of course is exactly the same as
what we just wrapped right it's still y
equals x okay now what happens when you
go to these quadrants well before I do
any of the algebra just think right if
one's positive ones negative right
you'll either have y equals negative x
or your mother x equals negative Y both
of which are exactly the same thing and
that's why you have this guy and that's
it that that is the absolute value of x
equals the absolute value of y not her
right
No Deal okay so that's it well now this
guy will take a little bit more time
okay the approach with all of these is
just to think about from the inside out
and just develop it slowly okay so I'm
gonna begin by doing my components you
ought to be getting to the point where
you can start to see if I give you just
a simple as you know you like that you
should be citing to get to the point
where you can see what it's doing
right where's X plus 1 it's gonna be
higher and then it should bounce right
so here
is the absolute value of x plus one
mm-hmm excuse me now
just as before see how I've got a
negative here right so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to draw an upside-down
absolute value graph where everything is
negative instead of everything being
positive okay so think right we'll do X
minus two person that's down here down
here so it would be bouncing over here
right that's the absolute value of X
minus two but before I do idiot I'm
going to turn it upside down okay so
this intercept over here is negative one
which means this intercept Dovahkiin
would be 2 right and I've got the same
kind of shape huh
okay so we've seen this before right now
would it draw this thing the subtraction
and then I'll make everything positive
right sir
I'm still not there yet and with my
components I'm gonna go from here all
the way down to here
and showed you the logic as to why I'm
adding these two graphs together I'm
adding them together so zero plus
something down here will be something
down here and zero plus something up
here you get the idea they're both
linear so the job the dots joining them
will also follow a linear pattern and
these guys are exactly opposite so I'm
getting this guy over here and then I've
got here right
finally I've drawn what's inside the
outside absolute value sight and now to
put these in place I think everything
down softly write everything okay so up
here this is all happy times cuz it's
all positive but over here this is going
to reflect upwards all right
so whatever that way the set was bit
would be it was going to be it's going
to be a wider set up here I'm guessing
something like this and a cross okay I
create I'm gonna have to find all of
these numbers but that's not that hard
right because if I want to find this
x-intercept here all I have to do is put
y equals zero into the whole thing right
and that's not that hard and I can do
the same thing for X whose already got
the values for
yeah listen can I have an exit set 1
over 2 and up at 1 which is because my
well my scale was pretty close
there you go what's your bad behavior ok
so that's it
all right now of course there's one more
step which is kind of helpful all of
these four branches they all have their
own equation ok you can already start to
anticipate what this equation is going
to be I think about it's above the axis
I've got a 1 I've got two what do you
thinks gonna be it's gonna be 3y plus 3
over here
y equals 3 over here cuz it would have
been negative 3 down there what's how
combined gradient in here and in here
it's - isn't it think about the pieces
that you've got what else could it be if
it was a 3 where would it get the 3 4
right so this is gonna be true X because
it's positive and then I'm gonna be
minus 1 right that's what the intercept
would have been which means that this
guy over here is going to be negative 2
X because it's decreasing and it has the
opposite minus X plus 1
I don't
this one in here okay all right I just
came over there I suppose if I want to
go into detail I would step back a bit
how did I get this blue equation in here
how do I get this right yeah good it's
the two great equations but it's in this
particular domain okay so to the right
over here I'm going to be taking the
positive cases for both which is why the
X is canceled
right and then over here I would have
taken the negative cases for both which
is why the XS cancel right but in
between here I've got two different ones
right think about this I'm gonna put my
green equations in here so good tell me
citizen what was this first one that I
drew what where is it it's equations
they came from here didn't they
so I've got X plus one over here that
would make this negative X minus one I'm
not interested in that though because
I'm in here yep what would the equation
of this plug-in function here doesn't it
this part in here has a positive
gradient right so this one's gonna be X
minus 2 okay this part would be 2 minus
X but I'm not interested in that part
okay it's equidistance very easy to work
out okay so now I have this part and
this part that's what's going to come
together right so the blue line is the
sum of these two okay so blue the
equation the blue line here would be y
equals 2x I've got a plus 1 and a
negative 2 so that should be minus 1
right and all I have to do is pop y
equals zero into this to find its x
intercept y equals 0 that would be 0
equals 2x minus 1 2 x equals 1 and
there's my X intercepts okay
so you can see how each step along the
way like having lots of colors is super
useful because you can tease apart all
the different steps and not go confused
on your cell phone okay
also in the same way if your diagram is
too small everything is just gonna all
the equations are just going to crowd
one another and it's gonna be very hard
to see okay any last questions on that
one before I do out forever
excellent okay this one's nice and easy
using a one color let's do that parabola
big guy okay no template required I'll
have some intercepts here don't I write
one of my x-intercepts - you have to -
and of course I'm down here at negative
4 because I'm shifted down okay so if I
snap the absolute value signs on the
whole thing what effect does that have
good yeah just like everything else has
been bouncing right this part in here is
gonna come out like this like that yep
and of course since I'm - that was
needed for before I should have four
okay I would just try and make sure that
this plan here should really be a
reflection this should come up with the
same gradient that this was going down
okay so it shouldn't be for instance
something like that you know the scale
would be off just watch out for those
kinds of little features
like that okay now it's a penny all the
way you think about it it's I've even
got two branches or three branches right
this inside part gets concave down if
this guy flipped around isn't it it's y
equals four minus x squared okay and
then these two parts on the outside they
each share the equation with the
positive place okay so they have the
same equation so you can kind of pick
them as two parts of the same branch but
they're separate so I think that it's
too great okay